henri ménudier bon jour bep/j merci
d'être avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
on le disait le ministre président
bavarois ne souhaite donc pas appliquée
l'obligation vaccinale pour les
personnes travaillant dans les hôpitaux
ou encore dans les maisons de retraite
précisément qu'est ce qu'ils avancent
comme argument pour quelles raisons
il y a un problème de fond du se pose en
elle-même c'est celui des droits
fondamentaux de la personne humaine qui
est inscrit à l'article 1 de la
constitution
vous savez que ces droits fondamentaux
avait été complètement bafouée sous le
troisième reich donc dans le système de
la république fédérale d'allemagne créée
en 1949 on a mis les droits fondamentaux
des personnes humaines au premier plan
donc le problème c'est maintenant de
savoir dans quelle mesure l'état le
fédéral où l'état au niveau régional
dans quelle mesure ces états ont-ils le
droit de limiter fortement la liberté
des libertés des citoyens des des
individus
derrière voudrais gagner un peu un peu
de temps pour montrer que elles se
montrent compréhensives à l'égard des
inquiétudes qui peuvent se manifester à
l'intérieur du du personnel du personnel
soignant et il faut savoir qu'il y avait
sur un derrière plusieurs luttes
politiques d'abord il ya des querelles
que le retour fréquemment entre l'état
fédéral et les régions dans la mesure où
il ya où les majorités politiques sont
différentes dans la capitale à berlin et
dans les länder les différentes régions
naturellement les
länder qui ne sont pas gouvernées par le
même parti dans les mêmes parts et que
ceux qui sont au pouvoir au niveau
fédéral ont toujours tendance à vouloir
chercher notre propre voix dense il ya
ce problème il y a également le fait que
prochainement il y aura des élections
élections régionales importantes en
allemagne surtout dans la partie
occidentale de l'allemagne naturellement
cela joue mais aussi à sept rôles dans
wana s'il voulait alors on a affaire
aussi un ministre d'un nouveau ministre
de la santé fédéral qui est du spd
monsieur n entre pas qui lui est assez
directif quelque peu autoritaire et
c'est ce qui provoque un conflit si vous
voulez avec sur la notion des droits
fondamentaux lui il voudrait imposer
l'obligation de vaccination est
naturellement les parties les autres
partis surtout les chrétiens démocrates
s'y opposent oui c'est une affaire
politique un tout petit peu un tout
petit peu compliqué à cela s'ajoute le
fait que du côté allemand on n'a pas
tout à fait réaliser les objectifs qui
étaient fixés une 80% de la population
devaient être vaccinés avant la fin de
l'année or au nom d asi même année
autour de 75 à 76 76 % donc va que les
mécanismes les décisions en allemagne à
cause du fédéralisme sont extrêmement
déçus mandat est compliqué parce que
c'est vrai que le chancelier olaf scholz
lui a soutenu une obligation vaccinale
pour tous les adultes d'ailleurs il en
est au de ce projet
oui il
cet été sa prise de position
contrairement la chancelière angela
merkel qui était beaucoup plus prudente
qui parlait d'une éventuelle obligation
de vaccination mais qui restent très
prudents en question les choses jeu
s'est engagé à agir rapidement sur ce le
buzz sur ce point de vue là et il a vu
tout de suite qu'il y avait une
opposition qui se manifester dans les
landes si bien que depuis ils restent
tout à fait il est plutôt en retrait et
il demande au parlement de prendre une
de prendre une décision du premier
décision le problème aussi du
gouvernement fédéral c'est que il fait
davantage plus confiance il peut être
davantage que dans ce gouvernement
précédent il fait davantage confiance
est un
organisme qui est chargé l'organisme le
scientifique ne aircal qui est chargé de
conseiller le gouvernement a le
gouvernement fédéral il ya un peu une
façon si vous voulez que ceux de se
défausser des responsabilités sur les
experts et cette approche fait confiance
eux ou seulement aux experts est
vivement critiqué par une partie de la
population
il faut voir que en allemagne comme en
france il ya maintenant une certaine
fatigue à l'égard des changements de
recommandations du gouvernement des
mesures de précaution ça fait maintenant
plus de deux ans que toutes ces mesures
sont appliquées donc du côté l'opinion
publique en voudrait en terminer et il
faut bien dire que la politique de
communication du gouvernement en matière
de lutte contre le corona virus n'a pas
toujours été très clair il ya eu des
retours en arrière beaucoup de personnes
ne comprennent plus grand chose dans des
obligations qui se présente donc si vous
voulez on essaie d'aller et maintenant
les processus et les mesures de
précautions pour que l'opinion publique
continue à soutenir la politique du
gouvernement alors fin 2001 la bavière
avait été submergée par les quatre
communes marcus slaughter s'était même
dit lui favorable à l'obligation
vaccinale généralisé sur le plan
national aujourd'hui il n'en veut plus
il ya un véritable risque à ce que les
soignants démissionne aujourd'hui à
cause de ses obligations vaccinales
lui si le risque si l'une arguments
qu'il utilise une des six mais on ne sut
en impose rapidement eu cette obligation
de réussite de vaccination du personnel
soignant ce personnel qui est hostile
qui refusent cette obligation est bien
risque soit de se mettre en congé
maladie ou bien risque de démissionner
et on aura plus de personnel des
cellules lui pas suffisant dans les
hôpitaux donc il dit attendons l'idée
d'une obligation
de vaccination n'est peut-être pas
mauvaise mais il faut pas l'imposer
aussi rapidement et d'autre part je sais
comme je vous ai dit tout à fait au
début il ya ce problème jeudi l'inde
ordre constitutionnel
beaucoup de personnes se réfère à cet
article de la constitution qui des
appels au respect des droits
fondamentaux
il ya d'ailleurs eu déjà des décisions
da par des tribunaux au niveau au niveau
régional et les décisions prises sans
variable il n'y a pas de véritable il
n'y a pas subi de véritables unités et
dans des décisions prises c'est à dire
que on peut être apprêtée la situation
juridique de façon différente alors
messieurs soldat est bien sûr très
prudent il essaie surtout de ne pas
perdre le contact avec son opinion son
opinion publique il est évident aussi
que silver profiter vu que maintenant là
les chrétiens-démocrates sens dans nos
positions eh bien ils n'hésitent plus à
s'opposer la peau hilti qui ai demandé
qui est
présenté par le gouvernement fédéral
dirigé par le spd merci beaucoup henry
menuisier pour votre éclairage ce matin
dans la matinale berthet france je le
rappelle vous êtes professeur honoraire
à la sorbonne et spécialiste de
l'allemagne